third seed UCLA will play Kent State in
the South Regional tonight one player to
watch is UCLA freshman Lanza ball the
star point guard is projected to be a
top NBA draft pick after just one year
in college and his two younger brothers
are dominating their high school
competition Dana Jacobson met the ball
brothers their mother and their
outspoken father
[Applause]
levar how many hours you think you guys
have spent on this court hours hours
let's say oh throughout the day high
five time 360 please you looking at it
3,000 levar ball built this backyard
basketball court with one goal in mind
Oh to turn the three ball brothers into
ball players Oh oldest Lonzo good pass
get him out of here
middle child lee angelo and the baby ha
lamelle oh okay so was this hey let's
have a family of basketball players I'll
tell you how that goes here goes to know
where he's gonna be playing basketball
you gotta have the right genes I had a
lot of short qts Pitino was a tall Wow
kaboom so I was like man you know what
I'm gonna get three boys Tina did you
did you know this was this was what
y'all that was the plan he said Tina I'm
gonna have boys I hope you don't want
girls
Lavar and Tina ball met when both played
college basketball and just as levar
predicted the couple's basketball genes
were passed along to their sons there
you go
I knew I had a brand once I had all
three of them it's gonna be the big
baller brand big brothers of course
those big ballers started off small and
it was kind of contradicting because
people's like look big ball isn't as
small as they are but after we finished
whooping that tail they knew who the big
ballers were and soon they weren't so
little well yeah this is what a big ball
is do they stuff the boys trained with
their father seven days a week even on
holidays
oh that dedication led to success
all three played together at Chino Hills
High School in Southern California their
encore chemistry up-tempo play and
unlimited range electrified packed
gymnasiums as they led the school to its
first undefeated season and a state
championship game which is a lot easier
you know when you get to play with
people you live with cm every day this
year as UCLA starting point guard Lonzo
led the nation in assists and propelled
the school to a number three seed in the
NCAA tournament 40 miles east at Chino
Hills his brothers haven't missed a beat
Melo do you miss having all three of you
there this year no I mean I get more
shots this year you had that the 92
point game oh yes lamellas 92 point
Green came just weeks after the Angelo
put up 72 points in an outing videos of
the brothers now regularly go viral this
one has been viewed more than half a
million times I told people when my boys
finished playing ball over here soon as
you say Chino Hills the first thing on
come out their mouth his ball brothers
and now it's happening and he's shocked
I'll just walk around smiling the bar
ball as you may have noticed it doesn't
exactly hold back when it comes to
talking up his boys comparing Lonzo to
NBA MVP Steph Curry one of several
headline-grabbing statements he's made
recently leading to criticism from some
sports writers and analysts people have
said you need to just be quiet and let
your kids play ball Jackson can tell you
what to words don't mean they don't mix
Navarre Bowl and shut up you can forget
that I even [ __ ] like that since I've
been born like I said now let me tell
you something there be shocked if I
didn't say nothing I laugh because
whoever they try to compare my boys to
he's gonna say they're better than it
doesn't matter who is that's what he
believes the bar is high and that's fine
with me that high bar leads to
competition in almost everything this
tight-knit family does who's winning you
think for us it's also created an
unmistakable bond between the boys and
their parents whether or not these three
basketball phenom all end up playing
the NBA as their father has predicted
get it's hard you know there is one
place you will always find them playing
ball there you go let me tell you guys
the backyard is always open whenever you
want to test your dad come on boom don't
kill your dad please come on throw that
strip away go we go get know right
Jill go anytime no any time for CBS News
Dana Jacobson Chino Hills California
before I heard this story I heard always
so obnoxious but after watching I think
he's great yeah I agree I loved a wife I
loved the mom I loved the whole thing
there is nothing better than having a
parent who cheers you on at every move
yeah go ball brother yeah and gives you
the kind of training you need to do
something special thank you right back